america's tech titans on the defensive
facebook's mark zuckerberg alphabets
sundar pichai
amazon's jeff bezos and apple's tim
cook all face the virtual grilling on
capitol hill
lawmakers say these ceos and their
companies are abusing their position
and crippling the competition many of
the practices used by these companies
have harmful economic effects
they discourage entrepreneurship destroy
jobs
hike costs and degrade equality simply
put
they have too much power for hours these
big tech ceos addressed allegations
including abuse of power
data surveillance and political
censorship why does google steal
content from honest businesses
i disagree with that characterization
just last week i met with many small
businesses
in fact today we support 1.4 million
small businesses
supporting over 385 billion dollars in
economic activity
amazon has nearly seven times the market
share of its closest
e-commerce competitor one seller told us
that and i quote
amazon continues to be the only show in
town
no matter how angry sellers get they
have nowhere else to go
so are you saying that these people
aren't being truthful
when they say that amazon is the only
game in town
yeah congresswoman with great respect i
do disagree with that
i believe that there are a lot of
options
cook and zuckerberg insisted their
companies aren't invincible
we don't have a dominant share in any
market
or in any product category where we do
business
new companies are created all the time
all over the world
and history shows that if we don't keep
innovating someone will replace every
company here today
that change can often happen faster than
you expect
also on display partisan divides
i'll just cut to the chase big tech's
out to get conservatives
that's not a suspicion that's not a
hunch that's a fact
republicans say these companies are
unfairly suppressing and censoring
conservative opinions and media
but democrats say big tech isn't going
far enough
in cracking down on misinformation and
hate speech
a lot to talk about let's look at this
now with rob watts from
dw business good morning to you rob nice
to see you again morning
um this hearing was billed as a day of
reckoning for big tech did it live up to
those expectations
well they certainly got a grilling or it
might be better to say a long
slow cooking because this was five hours
of questioning
on various aspects of their businesses
now this was in the us congress and
there was a certain amount of partisan
split between the questioning that they
were getting from the two sides for
example the democrats wanted to talk
a bit more about disinformation and then
you've got the republicans wanting to
accuse
these tech companies of suppressing
conservative voices of having
links to china those issues are not
really to do with competition
and anti-trust which is what the issue
at hand was supposed to be here so to
some extent they were
diluted and these major
figures in the tech industry were let
off the hook on those particular
issues there was also the issue that
some of these congress people didn't
perhaps know the
the subjects that they were discussing
to the extent that they might have hoped
for example at one point mark zuckerberg
was asked about donald trump jr tweeting
about hydroxychloroquine and having his
account suspended
obviously mark zuckerberg counted that
by saying well that was something that
happened on twitter
not on facebook but it was a
broad-ranging
discussion no real hits
landed i would say though okay we saw in
our piece there um
the bosses of the tech giants defending
themselves there were some tough
allegations
that they were facing yeah absolutely
and they
battered them all back i mean one of the
things that was quite surprising to see
was against these
allegations of you know being
uncompetitive
we heard uh for example mark zuckerberg
playing down
facebook's strength saying that in for
example the
sector of advertising facebook is a huge
player in that but he said well you know
we're not the biggest
google's the biggest and we're not the
fastest growing amazon is the the
fastest growing
advertising platform on the issue of
working with
china we've heard google being accused
of working with the chinese military
while turning down work with the u.s
military being accused of being
unpatriotic but sundar bichai said
well actually that's that's frankly just
false and then also amazon
being accused of driving small firms out
of business but jeff bezos saying well
actually
no american company has created more
american jobs than amazon
now apparently uh some congressional
probes are being planned one congressman
said
the firms should be broken up and after
they are they should be
tightly regulated what kind of
government action can we expect moving
forward
the big discussion is around this idea
of breaking them up but whether or not
we'll actually see that
i'm not so sure because for a start it
goes very much against the ethos of many
republicans to smash up a company and to
interfere
with it to that extent also some of them
will be
sympathetic to the tech giant's own
suggestion that by cutting them up what
you're effectively doing is giving the
chinese a head start their main
competitor but there seems little doubt
that
anti-trust laws in the united states do
need to be changed they need to be
updated they come from the 1800s you
know from the times of the railroad
long before we had the internet and we
had companies of this
size so expect to see an awful lot of
scrutiny of these tech companies
over the coming years particularly if
they try to expand
okay including uh modernizing the laws
that that would govern all of this
rob thanks so much for coming in rob
watts from dw business
you